les caducée aux vestiaires grève
national des médecins demain assemblée
nationale impasse dans la discussion sur
le budget
invité du journal michel de bâtisses
nouveau secrétaire d'état aux industries
agroalimentaires 1 messieurs bonsoir
neuf médecins sur dix en grève demain
c'est ce que croit savoir d'après un
sondage le quotidien du médecin il faut
dire que ce mot d'ordre de fermeture des
cabinets a été lancé par toutes les
organisations médicales
cela touchera surtout les généralistes
et la région parisienne un peu moins le
nord et le nord-est mais les urgences
seront assurées alors avec laurence
graff a maintenant le pourquoi de ce mot
d'ordre est d'abord les conseils
pratiques à donner aux patients et aux
malheurs de puissance alors qu'est-ce
qui va se faire grève et bien à peu près
de neuf mutation disney n'y aura pas
seulement les médecins mais aussi les
laboratoires quelques pharmacies dès
qu'ils y quelques dentiste aussi et il
est possible que certaines consultations
hospitalières publiques sont également
fermés mais il y aura toujours des
services d'urgence alors qu'est ce que
ça veut dire ça veut dire qu'à la
campagne et dans l'équipe
ce sera un petit peu comme le dimanche
il y aura des services de garde et dans
les grandes villes et notamment à paris
et bien il y aura des permanences pour
parler particulièrement on peut faire un
peu lan numéro c'est le seul 133 99 11
et de toute façon les médecins ou des
répondeurs aux indique l'adresse des
permanences et ils passeront aussi
vraisemblablement des affichettes à côté
de leur plaque
et puis enfin il est toujours possible
de recourir à l'hôpital mais il faut
savoir pourquoi les médecins font grève
ils sont de rêve d'abord contraint fait
c'est le blocage des honoraires qu'ils
étaient décidés en juillet et puis il
faudrait aussi contre ce qu'ils
considèrent comme une menace
c'est l'idée d'accrocher l'évolution des
dépenses médicales
les ordonnances et aussi les
consultations et les visites à
l'évolution de la richesse nationale
alors le mode enveloppe globale a été
prononcée en juillet par le ministre de
la santé et ce mot fait sur les médecins
à l'effet d'un chiffon rouge mais
toutefois au delà de la grève le plus
grand syndicale des médecins français la
csmf est en train de préparer un contre
projet le docteur monnier président de
la csmf nous en donne les grandes lignes
je crois que c'est le moment de réunir
je crois d'urgence une sorte de grande
conférence nationale de la santé à cette
conférence sociale de la santé devrait
être invitée bien sûr le gouvernement au
niveau le plus élevé bien sûr les
représentants des caisses mais les
représentants des organisations
syndicales représentant les assurés
sociaux des représentants bien sûr du
patronat et des médecins il faut que
nous soyons là au moins comme expert
pour dire ce qui est possible ce qui est
souhaitable et après le gouvernement
décide et je veux attirer l'attention de
l'opinion sur un point c'est que nous ne
renonçons pas à nos responsabilités nous
en avons mais nous acceptons de prendre
les responsabilités après les choix
fondamentaux et il est beaucoup plus
facile de faire admettre par les
médecins un par un dans le cas d'une
auto discipline de la profession de
jouer le jeu de choix qui ont été faits
clairement que plutôt que des choix qui
sont faits dans la plus parfaite
irresponsabilité en repoussant sur le
médecin des décisions qui n'auraient pas
été prises sur le plan politique
la semaine dernière les caisses de
sécurité sociale ont prévenu les
médecins qu'elle était prête pour la
négociation du côté de le ministère de
la santé on dit également tout est
négociable
il faut absolument arriver à une
maîtrise de dépenses de la santé en fait
le problème il peut se résumer en deux
chiffres les dépenses de santé en france
augmentent actuellement de 21 % par an
et la richesse du pays elles elles
augmentent de 14%
voilà en tout cas une greffe qui
intéressera au premier chef un malade
pas comme les autres est mon bar qui est
toujours hospitalisé au val de grâce et
dans l'état de santé évolue de façon
satisfaisante viennent nous dire un
communiqué le premier ministre devrait
quitter sa chambre à la fin de la
semaine
les médecins ne souhaite pas qu'il
s'absente demain quelques heures pour se
rendre à l'assemblée nationale et
pourtant il s'en passe des choses à
l'assemblée les députés viennent tout
simplement de rejeter la loi d'
équilibre du budget at revin c'est à
dire le fameux article 25 socialistes et
communistes ont voté contre c'était
attendu
ce qui l'était moins c'est que le rpr
s'est abstenu résultat la première
partie de loi de finances est à dire le
vote des recettes n'est pas adoptée
alors jusqu alors pour parler dépenses
il fallait déjà avoir adopté les
recettes alors daniel brême comment on
va s'en sortir le parlement par vous
l'avez dit sans précédent dans les
annales de la 5e et c'est la première
fois depuis 21 ans qu'un groupe de la
majorité en l'occurrence le rpr refuse
donc de voter la première partie de la
loi de finances alors il fallait innover
et évidemment quand il faut innover
tout le monde n'est pas toujours
d'accord alors il ya eu à cette occasion
encore nous tempête car monsieur fabius
socialiste estimé que puisque il n'y
avait pas de recette qu'il ne pouvait y
avoir de dépenses et donc tous devaient
être bloquées on devait s'arrêter là le
président chaban delmas qui avait pris
la vie d'un certain nombre de juristes a
estimé que la discussion pouvait
continuer motif la loi dans son
organique est invoqué dans son article
40 10 il doit y avoir un vote sur les
recettes mais bien opportunément elle ne
prévoit pas si le vote est positif ou
négatif
donc cette nuit on commencera l'examen
du budget de l'éducation nationale mais
le rendez-vous gouvernement rpr n'est en
fait que reportée car la fin de la
discussion budgétaire est prévu pour le
16 ou le 17 novembre
et c'est là sans doute que le
gouvernement qui voudra récupérer son
budget qui est devenu absolument
monstrueux comme le disait tout à
l'heure lucien neuwirth sera sans doute
obligée de poser la question de
confiance à moins que le rpr ne soit
revenu à de meilleurs sentiments ce qui
n'est pas certain
bien voilà donc daniel pour l'évolution
des choses comment est-ce qu'on en est
arrivé là bien écouter souvenez-vous
depuis un certain temps le groupe rpr
avait dit et redit nous ne voterons pas
les recettes si nous n'obtenons pas les
deux milliards d'économies qui devront
être reportés sur les investissements et
bien cet amendement ayant été repoussée
et bien immédiatement le rpr a fait
preuve de sa détermination alors il a
mis sa menace à exécution mais je peux
vous dire que je n'ai jamais vu une
discussion budgétaire aussi incohérente
à tel point qu'il y avait tellement de
subtilité que les présidents des deux
groupes de la majorité ont jugé plus
prudent de venir successivement devant
les journalistes pour expliquer la façon
dont on devait interpréter le fond de
leur pensée parce que derrière toutes
ces subtilités il ya plus grave
eh bien oui il ya effectivement derrière
la bataille des chiffres quelque chose
de beaucoup plus grave il ya une lutte
politique
acea le rpr souvenez vous après le
discours de chirac a voulu démontrer qu
il pesé suffisamment pour modifier
l'orientation de toute la politique
gouvernementale
économie le gouvernement ne peut
accepter lui que l'on mette en cause une
politique et un budget qui a été décidé
en conseil des ministres sous l'autorité
du président de la république pour le
cas échéant affirmé ce soir monsieur
chine ou dans les couloirs dénoncer
ensuite la faiblesse de ce gouvernement
alors dans sa résistance le ministre du
budget monsieur papon et bien se
retrouver tout seul avec lui des et
pourtant dans l'après midi les députés
de la majorité avait adopté un
amendement pour la baie de roger chinaud
permettant au parlement de se prononcer
sur l'évolution des dépenses sociales de
la nation
deux autres gros sujet de conversation
dans le monde politique d'abord les
suites de la victoire de l'âme
majorité à aix en provence au municipal
dès le premier tour
salué par michel pinton qui voit là une
confirmation éclatante de la stratégie
de l'udf en revanche au ps on y découvre
plutôt je cite les fruits amers de la
politique de division du pc cela doit
nous amener à ne plus juste appréciation
de l'alliance privilégiée avec le parti
communiste qui devient de moins en moins
crédible dit même charlie milo qui
dirige le ps dans les bouches du rhône
du côté communiste on rejette la
responsabilité de l'échec sur les
socialistes qui dit-on là bas n'ont pas
joué échec également de l'union de la
gauche aux municipales de digoin dans la
saône et loire
mieux la gauche a perdu cette mairie une
jolie consolation tout de même pour le
ps qui récupère un siège au parlement
européen de strasbourg ainsi en a décidé
le conseil d'état suivant cela la
recommandation du commissaire du
gouvernement et retirant un siège à la
liste veille désormais 25 élus pour
cette dernière 22 pour les socialistes
et les radicaux de gauche
réaction du socialiste lionel jospin
cette décision rétablit le bon droit
nous avions raison à l'époque de parler
de batman heures et deux sièges volée et
puis résultats concrets edgard pisani
socialiste va siéger à strasbourg
mais curieusement olivier d'ormesson qui
était le dernier de la liste udf avoir
été élu et qui donc aurait dû céder son
siège le gardera il le gardera parce que
l'un de ces colistiers vient aujourd'hui
de démissionner michel débâtisse a en
effet été nommé cet après midi comme
nous le laissions entendre secret d'état
auprès du premier ministre chargé de
l'industrie agricole et alimentaire
avant de le recevoir
tout d'abord que nous expliquions avec
jean-louis calmejane ce qu'est
l'agroalimentaire l'agroalimentaire se
sont tous les produits agricoles qui ont
subi une transformation et en france 60%
de la production agricole et transformé
l'agroalimentaire c'est donc aujourd'hui
une véritable industrie qui concerne
tout le monde
l'agriculteur d'abord c'est lui qui
produit l'aliment l'industriel ensuite
c'est lui qui le transforme le
consommateur enfin c'est lui qui le
mange cette industrie se situe en france
à la deuxième place après les bâtiments
et les travaux publics
elle emploie 600 mille personnes dans
plus de 4000 entreprises
son point fort ce sont ces possibilités
d'exportation les vins et spiritueux par
exemple se vendent très bien à
l'étranger
on a pris une certaine avance dans ce
secteur et le précise français fait le
reste
cela marche très bien aussi pour les
céréales et le sucre mais pour ces deux
produits
on n'a pas beaucoup de mérite à les
vendre à l'extérieur ils s'exportent
tout seul et on n'a pas à faire d'effort
de promotion par contre les produits qui
doivent subir plus de transformation
comme les biscuits la confiture la
poudre de lait ou le beurre tous ces
produits se vendent mal à l'étranger car
on ne fait pas assez d'efforts pour les
promouvoir
à titre de comparaison les hollandais
dépensent plus d'argent pour promouvoir
leurs produits laitiers en france que
les français n'en dépense pour
promouvoir l'ensemble de tous leurs
produits agricoles sur tous les marchés
mondiaux
l'expansion de la production agricole
française fasse inéluctablement par une
expansion de nos exportations
agroalimentaires et aujourd'hui les
professionnels c'est-à-dire les
agriculteurs comme les industriels
doivent participer eux-mêmes à la
promotion de leurs produits à l'étranger
ce sera l'un des premiers rôles du
secrétariat d'état aux industries
agroalimentaires
alors michel de battice et y est vous
avez basculer vous n'êtes plus
syndicaliste vous êtes un homme
politique ne ratez pas ce choix
non je crois que dans certaines périodes
à certains moments lorsque les choses se
présentent il faut accepter les
responsabilités qu'on vous confie et
c'est ce que le président de la
république m'a demandé de prendre cette
responsabilité qui est importante pour
le pays
je vais essayer de l'assumer je dirais
comme j'ai assumé dans le passé des
responsabilités syndicales
vous n'avez l'impression de trahir la
salle de soin pas du tout je rentre que
le les agriculteurs comme l'ensemble des
français ont besoin justement que le
vote revalorisé de générer de leroy
c'est entendu mais que de valoriser ce
qu'il produit nous avons là un retard
considérable par rapport aux autres pays
mais justement michel dumas dit vous
savez que vous avez eu un prédécesseur
ce cadre il ya des tas et les gentils
périssat pas toujours jean tiberi mais
il n'est pas resté bien longtemps à
peine un an
est ce que ça vous fait pas peur si mais
si je mesure bien là
la difficulté de la tâche la seule chose
que je me dis c'est que je vais essayer
de profiter de l'expérience de mes
prédécesseurs de jean tiberi est aussi à
l'heure actuelle du délégué à
l'aménagement de déléguer aux ânes
extrait colle alimentaire monsieur jean
van bon et puis la différence elle est
importante je suis secrétaire d'état
auprès du premier ministre c'est à dire
qu'il y a à la face au ministère il
arrive à la cheville serriculture donc
la possibilité sous l'autorité du
premier ministre
de pouvoir arbitrer entre les positions
défendues par me lavais culture par
l'amith l'industrie voir parler finance
sur un certain nombre de questions
or c'est à partir de là et fort de cette
confiance du président la république que
je vais essayer de faire en sorte que
l'industrie agroalimentaire nous
permettent à nous français au fond de
jouer le rôle qu'on doit j'ai pris dans
la république a pris cette formule à
vassy notamment il a parlé du pétrole
devait est-ce que c'est pas une grande
formule pour une petite réalité ou bien
c'est une
c'est une je dirais grandes formules
mais qui dit bien ce qu'il veut dire
n'est ce pas le pétrole c'est quelque
chose qui se vend cher et bien puisque
la france elle un jeu l'indiquent 35% la
surface agricole de l'ensemble de la
communauté européenne
c'est qu'elle a une matière première
importante des hommes compétents mais
elle n'a pas une véritable industrie de
transformation n'a pas véritable action
commerciale de première main comme les
néerlandais comme les danois ne sait pas
bien si cela qu'il s'agit de construire
et c'est ce que je vais m'efforcer de
faire au cours des des mois et des
années qui viennent où il ya bonnes
chances de votre mission
l'actualité à l'étranger maintenant à
commencer par la suite de la démission
de monsieur bayonne le ministre
israélien des affaires étrangères une
démission qui va affaiblir le grenat
béguines et qui semble être accueillie
avec regret à jérusalem
ces images en cisjordanie et surtout à
washington où l'on jugé moshe dayan
suffisamment souffle pour infléchir la
politique israélienne
alors tous ne sont pas d'accord avec
cette façon de voir ainsi l'ambassadeur
israélien à paris qui rectifie un petit
peu l'image d'un day and plus colombes
que faucon on voit que toute la presse y
compris des gouvernements étrangers sont
en train de se lamenter sur le départ de
monsieur diane je crois que c'est
effectivement éminemment regrettable
qu'il soit parti mais ces mêmes
gouvernements
il ya encore 24 heures attaquer mais le
ce même monsieur dyan d'intransigeance
alors ce qu'il faut clarifier ce que
monsieur dyan n'a jamais été lui non
plus en faveur d'un état palestinien
il n'a jamais été lui non plus en faveur
du négociations avec l'ol paie le départ
de monsieur dejan concerne la technique
de la négociation j'ai concert
l'autonomie puisse contaminer appel ce
plongeur il voulait être plus mêlé à ct
négociations sur l'autonomie sur le plan
intérieur vous pensez que la démission
de monsieur on chez dai hành risque
d'affaiblir le gouvernement où
paradoxalement de le renforcer dans la
mesure où il n'y aura plus de voix
discordantes au sein du cabinet bien je
ne crois pas qu'il s'agit ici d'un rat
force renforcement d'un affaiblissement
y aura probablement un certain
remaniement ministériel et israël est un
pays démocratique
tant que le gouvernement a la majorité
parlementaire nécessaire et il
continuera à gouverner
c'est d'ailleurs le seul état au moyen
orient qui en dépit d'un état de guerre
permanent a toujours tenu les élections
à la date prévue
que ce soit sur le régime travailliste
avant ou au moment où il ya eu le
changement d'équipé avec la venue au
pouvoir du likoud
vous ne croyez pas l'éventualité
d'élections anticipées
écoutez venant dé jérusalem je me
garderai bien de faire des prophéties je
ne crois pas au stade actuel qui aura
des élections anticipées
votre réaction dans le monde arabe cette
fois à amman en jordanie si la radio
jourdanie hainard
allons c'est que ce n'est qu'une
manoeuvre politique personnelle de
l'ancien ministre vert étrangères
monsieur bayane quant à moscou l'agent
stas estiment que cette démission marque
le point culminant des divergences de la
politique
israël belgique maintenant nombreux ont
été les téléspectateurs français à
s'étonner des images que nous voyons ici
que nous avions diffusé hier soir en est
du journal cette charge à cheval de la
police flamande de liège ils ont alors
découvert que cette guerre linguistique
qui déchire ce que l'on appelle les
fourons c'est à dire un ensemble de six
villages francophones ont regroupé en
une commune est rattachée depuis 17 ans
à la province flamande du limbourg alors
au delà des heures d'hier des 30 blessés
et des centaines d'arrestations
il y en ait fait une série de petits
faits la vie quotidienne à l'église au
café à l'école que nous décrit bien ce
reportage nous a mis la rtb un si joli
village une campagne prospère un paysage
rayant à la normande tout devrait
inciter à la paix s'il n'y avait la
querelle linguistique l'absorption
légale à 1963 d'une population de langue
française
les wallons dans une province de langue
néerlandaise
oh
les communions c'est l'événement
aujourd'hui harry murs talent dans les
fourons le cortège traverse tous les
petits villages pour les communions
c'est un jour solennel ici rémusat l'on
parle français et là mais 7 en français
mais ici c'est l'exception ailleurs dans
les fourons les messes de communion sont
en flamand commence à en avoir marre
vous a bien eus mais sur quel jour en
français il ne veut pas non mais pas
déconner d'un pays fort mots tu crois
qu'il ya des banlieues c'est à dire à
bon dieu avant le compte sur la place de
l'église
il y a trois cafés deux cafés
francophones à café flamand
oh
je suis assis à la terrasse du premier
quartier francophone à fouron le quand
il y a trois cafés des cas ces
francophones à café flamand
je suis à la terrasse de l'autre
quartier francophone a souvent le compte
trois cafés dont me voici à la terrasse
du café flammes que voulez-vous
aujourd'hui les cafés à four en sont une
île at les écoles aussi
ceci c'est l'école primaire unilingue
francophone de fourons c'est une
nouveauté avant 1963
pratiquement tous les petits fouronnais
suivait les cours dans les deux langues
voici l'école unilingue flamande des
fourons y signa le dégré primaire et
depuis 68 degré secondaire
tu parle le français ou pas un peu la
tension vécue quotidiennement se réflète
ici au conseil communal de fourons le
rapport de force 10 francophones dont le
bourgmestre contre simplement à droite
souhaiteront en début de séance
interpellation d'un conseiller communal
flamand sur des incidents récents se
marre t il parlant pas toi les flamands
s'étaient de la signature des autres
dans le bourg numéro deux il est clair
que vous êtes des marionnettes mais
quelques titres aux riverains ayant qui
se sont installés ici un succulent aziez
que la personne qui a été inquiété or la
roma je fus témoin s'il vous plaît oui
oui en connaissaient toujours nous
l'aimons
depuis 1963 il est humain affrontements
comme celui d'hier mains de protestation
les drapeaux noirs ici par les
fouronnais ne date pas d'hier déjà
autant de la télévision belge
où est le temps où la télévision belge
n'existait qu'en noir et blanc il faut
quand même ramener les choses à leur
juste proportion
sur près de 10 millions de sujets belle
descente 4000 les fouronnais et si la
guerre linguistique empoisonne les
relations
il ne semble pas qu'il menace l'unité de
la belgique mais quand même dans le
silence de la nuit les coeurs ne sont
pas apaisées
enfin un dernier gros type de
l'actualité internationale le procès des
dissidents prague ils sont six
contestataires apparaître depuis
aujourd'hui devant un tribunal si
contestataires à qui lui reprochent
d'avoir précisément fondé un comité de
défense des personnes injustement
poursuivis par exemple les militants de
la fameuse charte 77 l'un d'entre eux
exilé en france pavel tigrid explique ce
qui là bas
l'enchaînement de répression tous ont
signé la charte 77 7 à 10 euros signait
le document qui demande au gouvernement
tchécoslovaque d'appliquer la
constitution qui est valable évidemment
est aussi d'appliquer les clauses
humanitaire désagréments à dire sig
voilà tout voilà les cris et quand on
n'est pas d'accord avec le gouvernement
une typo slovaquie comment ça se passe
concrètement tous les jours c'est dur
c'est à dire c'est à dire on frappe à
votre porte à 5 heures du matin on dit
c'est la police d'ouvrir la porte et on
fait la fouille d'une façon brutale et
après c'est le panier à salade et à
voilà qu'est ce que c'est parce
aujourd'hui c'est les au rayon des
mauvais traitements torture si beaucoup
mais vous savez c'est pas amusant d'être
d'être dans la met dans les mains d une
police politique qui est qu'est ce qu'il
est parce que le régime tchèque 7 un
régime dur d'un régime l'âge c'est un
régime qui opère il appert parce que
exactement 68 on avis qu'est ce que ça
donne que personne personne ne revient
pas donc avec les parties et monsieur ça
qu'est ce que risquent les gens qui sont
jugés aujourd'hui deux trois dix ans en
prison
très nombreuses protestations en france
d'abord ce matin une marche silencieuse
près de l'ambassade de tchécoslovaquie
le pcf en est-elle pcf qui demandent
l'acquittement des accusés ce procédé
les communistes porte préjudice au
développement la société socialiste à
son image à l'idéal pour lequel nous
luttons réaction des socialistes par la
bouche de georges fillioud la
déclaration du pcf est affaire de
circonstances en bref maintenant
toujours à l'étranger jess bishop aux
états unis exécuter ce matin à la prison
d'état du nevada
jess bischoff avait refusé de faire
appel et avait interdit à sa famille de
s'opposer à son exécution
bonne deuxième étape du numéro un
chinois après la france profonde est
arrivé aujourd'hui en république
fédérale allemande le premier entretien
qu'il a eu avec helmut schmidt a porté
sur la réunification de l'allemagne puis
pour l'instant en chine
le quotidien du peuple avertit les
mauvais garçons de pékin ce qu'ils
boivent du vin en flirtant dans les
restaurants vous avez intérêt à mieux
soutenir dit le quotidien du peuple
salle comble à un lice pour le procès de
ce qu'on appelle le casse du siècle
devant le tribunal six accusés inculpé
impliqué dans le cambriolage de la
société générale 6 accusés mais pas le
cerveau présumé albert spaggiari paul
feig quitte à nice nous rend compte
maintenant de cette première journée
d'audience
c'est paraît-il une boutade que de dire
qu'à nice les choses ne se passent
jamais comme ailleurs ce procès en est
c'est vrai un parfait exemple
voyez plutôt albert spaggiari le
principal accusé n'est pas là en fait on
ne sait même pas s'il est vivant et
quelques rumeurs nécrologie circuler
même ce matin à nice
en tout cas son cas a été séparée des
autres et il sera jugé plus tard
peut-être l'argent 4 milliards et demi
d'anciens francs a disparu pas pour tout
le monde bien sûr et même les lingots
d'or récupéré chez certains truand ne
sont pas présentés parmi lesquels sa
conviction et pour cause on ne sait
jamais une fois suffit enfin il au
terroir une bonne douzaine d'hommes qui
autour d'un pastis nécessaire au contact
humain doit suivre dans les environs
avec attention le déroulement des
audiences
ce sont les amis politiques entre
guillemets d'albert spaggiari
ce sont aux quelques traits en kit
depuis un sabre de moi mais si mais si
je suis innocent et personne ne les
crois
c'est enfin à l'homme où la femme
d'ailleurs pourquoi pas qui a indiqué la
sphère albert spaggiari lui non plus où
elle n'a jamais été retrouvé par les
policiers
pourtant malgré tant de vide l'acte
d'accusation fait 100 pages et le procès
durera dix jours dix jours c'est à peu
près le même temps qu'il a fallu aux
truands pour creuser le fameux tunnel
automutilation pour se faire entendre
maurice le qu'un condamné à 12 ans de
prison a envoyé au mythe à la justice
d'une de ses phalanges qu'il s'était
lui-même coupé maurice lecat se dit
innocent du hold up pour lequel il a été
condamné et eu recours à cette ultime
protestation pour alerter l'opinion
premières conséquences du raz de marée à
nice le projet du nouveau port de la
côte d'azur va être reconsidéré c'est ce
qu'a annoncé le ministre des transport
joël le theule aragon à la télévision
c'est un événement depuis longtemps en
effet le poète des yeux d'elsa
l'écrivain des cloches de bâle avait
renoncé à paraître sur le petit écran
et bien pour l'organisateur raoul sangla
y pour antenne 2 aragon sens yonne 3
tiendra avec un autre poète communiste
jean ristat six émissions d'une heure
lui sont consacrés la première ce soir à
21h40 un autre visage d'aragon au propre
et au figuré pendant les premiers volets
de la série d'émissions ce n'est pas ce
visage que vous retrouverez ragon
portera un masque de plastique blanc
provocation désir de cacher sa
vieillesse goût du théâtre comédie ou
tragédie comédie personnel il ne
dévoilera ses rides qu'au fil des heures
mais avec ou sans masque tout près à ces
mystères aragon a les siens multiples
qu'il ne livre pas sur commande pour
approcher le personnage de plus près et
tenter de délier le vrai de la légende
l'obscur du lumineux il fallait une
caméra qui prennent le temps de suivre
les méandres d'une pensée fle
une pensée dans la forme éblouissante
rejaillit depuis un demi siècle sur la
poésie de notre temps hier c'était la
guerre et j'avais 20 ans sais tu sais tu
toi que j'attends qu'ils ne vient pas
qui ne vient plus je m'en doutais et
tout ce bruit où je me tais où je
n'entend qu'un reer au loin des temps
ensemble
c'est en ces temps que tout se tait j'ai
tout tenté pour oublier le coeur mon
trembles est pourtant toujours un coeur
un coeur toujours qui bat l'angle d'un
coeur et un dans la forêt ragon à 21h40
après cartes sur table deuil dans le
monde de la musique nadia boulanger
morte ce matin à 92 ans elle avait formé
plusieurs générations de musiciens
français et étrangers par exemple
leonard bernstein & igor markevitch
marathon monstre au pays des 25 millions
de joggers new york était lié à l'eau
rendez-vous des quatorze mille
concurrents qui participaient au
marathon le plus célèbre et le plus
grandiose dans les rues même de la ville
au gratte ciel
un beau dimanche les flux indien 14
personnes en 2005 est un marathon
mammouth à travers les rues de new york
moyenne d'âge 35 ans les statistiques
précises même
marathonien moyens et marié qu'il a des
enfants qu'il travaille dans
l'enseignement le plus jeune a 9 ans le
plus âgé 80 et dans le peloton près de
300 français dont fernand kolbeck cinq
fois champion de france sur la distance
il terminera 11e 1,7 en misant engagé
quand on sait que les organisateurs
avaient écarté autant de demandes
d'inscription
on comprend mieux pourquoi les états
unis sur le royaume du jogging d'autant
que deux millions de spectateurs
s'étaient déplacés pour assister au
résultat le plus remarquable de la
journée celui obtenu par une jeune
norvégienne grete waitz qui en 2 heures
27 minutes 33 secondes à réaliser la
meilleure performance mondiale féminine
de tous les temps dans le marathon
quant au vainqueur bill rodgers il a 31
ans il vit à boston et fêté hier son
quatrième succès consécutif dans
l'épreuve deuxième un autre américain
qui a fait peur troisième un britannique
stephen kenya oui se dit en passant si
vous avez une bonne traduction du mot
joggers
écrivez nous nous avons déjà trouvé
trois tinner mais cela ne nous fait pas
beaucoup
pour terminer ce journal nous allons
mart et météo bien sûr comme d'habitude
aujourd'hui les nuages parfois
accompagnés de pluie ont été abondants
sur les pyrénées le bassin aquitain et
le massif central
nous découvrons ici c'est ainsi que sur
les régions méditerranéennes
demain on nous annonce un temps médiocre
sur la majeure partie du pays
un temps souvent nuageux à couvert avec
des pluies intermittentes de région
quand même quelque peu à l'abri de ce
mauvais temps le sud-ouest et les
régions du nord de la france
les prochains rendez vous que vous
fixent la rédaction d'antenne 2 d'abord
tout de suite après ce journal à 20h35
donc l'avortement la conception la
contraception la drogue la famille ce
sont les grands thèmes évoqués par
monique pelletier ministre déléguée à la
condition féminine qui sera interrogé
par jean-pierre elkabbach et alain
duhamel pour cartes sur table et puis en
fin de soirée c'est à dire vers 23h20
pierre-alain pour les toutes dernières
informations
bonsoir à tous à demain